jacques bonneau bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
disait 1208 commune de 30 départements
ont décidé de rendre le port du masque
obligatoire en extérieur le mont saint
michel ont fait partie qu'est ce qui a
motivé cette décision
bonjour alors effectivement le port du
masque sur le mont saint michel est
obligatoire la motivation principale est
le retour des touristes locaux et
européens et la configuration des lieux
sur la rue principale ne permet pas la
distanciation physique entre les
touristes donc le port du masque est
rendue obligatoire de 10 heures à 18
heures qui est la période où il ya le
plus d'affluence avant et après le port
du masque baby g et on se rend compte
que malgré le fait qu'il ne soit pas
obligatoire
les personnes avant 10 heures et après
18h maintiennent le port du masque dans
cette partie de la commune qui est le
rocher
alors justement vous l'avais dit la
mesure elle est imposée de 10h à 18h
tous les jours pour les personnes âgées
depuis de 11 ans est-ce que vous
parvenez à faire respecter ces consignes
comment est-ce qu'on réagit à la
population sur place
alors le depuis le la fin du
déconfinement le port du masque d'or la
commune du mont a toujours été
obligatoire hormis deux semaines mais
ils n'étaient uniquement obligatoire le
week-end et jours fériés sur l'affluence
était moindre et on s'est rendu compte
que malgré le fait qu'ils ne soient pas
obligatoires le reste de la semaine
les personnes portées de même le masque
parce que ce rendez compte que la
configuration des lieux ne permettait
pas justement cette distanciation
physique et on s'aperçoit que la la la
mesure est réellement bien accepté et
c'est pour ça que les élèves et les
personnes le porte sans contrainte et je
n'ai pas de réclamations j'ai plutôt des
messages en mairie de de sympathie ou de
personnes qui me disent avoir pris la
bonne décision et cette mesure et est
comprise elle a deux vertus en plus
la première c'est que le port du masque
physique limite la propagation du virus
c'est là ça a été dit les roddick et
l'autre vertu c'est une vertu et
psychologique
ça rappelle au public
dans une situation un petit peu atypique
oui nous pouvons circuler librement
mais faisons quand même attention à
hauteur hui et à autre personne et le
port du masque rappel ça c'est à dire
que ça cette dimension psychologique de
se dire oui ne sommes pas dans une
configuration normale
confiné pendant deux mois le mont saint
michel a rouvert ses commerces aux
visiteurs le 11 mai et c'est cafés les
restaurants le 2 juin est ce que c'était
trop tôt est ce que finalement c'était
la bonne date
selon vous alors comme tous les lieux
publics en france je pense que c'était
la bonne la bonne de la bonne décision
tout en sachant que le mont lorsqu'il a
été d confiné l'influencent est revenu
progressivement faire au bout de deux
mois
la première chose morceaux lorsqu'on
sort d'un confinement
c'est pas se dire la chouette je bois et
au moins cinq jeunes non c'était d'aller
faire les choses qu'on n'a pas pu faire
en deux mois d'aller voir la famille des
amis et des plumes aux autres sa bague
donc là à la venue du public s'est fait
vraiment très très progressif et c'est
pour ça que nous appuyons imposer le
port de masques uniquement le week-end
et c'était uniquement avec locaux
limitée à moins de 100 kg mais
maintenant nous sommes dans une
configuration autres à savoir le retour
en masse des visiteurs vous retrouve la
même fréquence que dans les années 2015
à savoir environ dix mille personnes par
jour lors de week-ends est effectivement
là la différence ce sont des touristes
locaux
j'appelle aux pôles nationaux et
européens nous n'avons pas là
l'affluence des visiteurs asiatiques
alors l'arrêté prévoit de maintenir
cette restriction jusqu'au 30 septembre
escaut selon vous cette mesure pourrait
être prolongée alors dans le système de
mesure où nous avons mis en place j'ai
instauré avec les municipalités 3 3
niveaux d' alerte le niveau 3 comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est pas du
bassin uniquement jours fériés et
week-end de 10h à 18h ça c'est niveau 3
nous sommes passés en a l'air ce que
j'appelle niveau 2 port du masque
obligatoire de 10 heures à 18 heures
tous les jours
et pourquoi niveau 2 où on entend
partout
en bretagne dans le nord des foyers de
contamination qui se créent et l'arrivée
du public maaf nous a fait prendre la
décision demain de monter au niveau d
alerte 2 et nous avons un niveau d'
alerte 1
si on s'aperçoit que la pandémie et
revient c'est le port du masque est le
sens de circulation unique pour éviter
le croissement des visiteurs dans la rue
et après il ya le niveau d' alerte 0 la
scène où le moi ni la municipalité corso
m c'est le confinement comme nous avons
connu au mois de début d'année
merci jacques bonneau pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
maire du mont saint michel